so today I am very excited to have dr.
David Bates with me dr. Bates is the
chief of general medicine at Brigham and
Women's Hospital where he's also the
chief quality officer but the real
reason we have and beyond those very
important positions he has is that he
has been the sort of pioneer in studying
patient safety health information
technology and how they intersect Dave
thank you so much for coming thanks for
having me so I want to start off by
first taking a theoretical example here
we are at the Harvard School of Public
Health where right across the street
from Brigham and Women's Hospital
imagine the Brigham is a typical
American Hospital and I am a patient I
have some illness and I go to the
hospital I go to the Brigham
what am i at risk from an adverse event
patient safety point of view what are
bad things that could happen to me if
I'm at the hospital of course we try to
do as much as we can to keep you from
getting any of those bad things but the
fact is that there are a number of
things that can happen you could have an
adverse drug event probably harmed by a
medication so I'm going to just take a
minute and write these down so I'd
restrict about keep going yes it could
have a hospital-acquired infection okay
so I'm going to call that H AI hospital
acquired infection you could fall you
could develop a pressure ulcer okay you
could have a surgical complication okay
and you could have a deep venous
thrombosis those are really the main
causes of harm okay call that DVT deep
venous thrombosis so let's go through
each of these a little bit more
carefully adverse drug event how do you
think about it what is an adverse drug
event an adverse drug event is any
injury that's caused by medication okay
and about how often do these occur in a
typical let's say American or sort of
Western Hospital they happen in between
seven and sixteen four hundred
admissions
so infections it's about three per
hundred admission okay crawl is about 1%
pressure ulcer is about 3% surgical
complication is about 2% the FF surgery
obviously a complication and deep venous
thrombosis is about 1% so none of these
numbers offhand look very big but is
this a big problem it is a big problem
when you add them up turns out that
somewhere between 10 and 25% of patients
who come to the hospital have something
bad happen to them as the result of the
hospitalization what the exact numbers
depends a little bit on how hard you
work is a uniquely American problem
David now we now have studies from all
over the world that show that the radio
farm is is up on the order of this
magnitude in most of the international
studies which have come from developed
countries the rate has been about ten
and a hundred admissions